In the early days of computing,
programmers needed to be very sure about the
data they were operating on.
If an operation was fed a number when it was
expecting a letter, a character:
at best you might get a garbled response,
and at worst you could break the system.
Maybe even physically.
Now, at the low level of coding,
yeah, that’s still true.
But these days we have
programming languages where
we don’t always need to be
so rigorous in defining the data,
and we can let the computer figure it out.
But for something that seems so technical,
this can be controversial.
When you write a computer program,
you use variables,
which are basically just labelled
buckets of memory.
Inside that bucket is some data,
and you can change it,
you can vary it.
Hence, variable.
I know it’s a massive simplification,
but computer memory is a bit like
an enormous rack of switches
storing ones and zeros that represent other
things like letters and numbers.
But if we look into a region of memory,
there is nothing in there to indicate what
those ones and zeros are actually representing.
So in the code, we declare that the variable
is a particular type.
What's contained in that variable,
in that bucket?  It's an integer.
What's in that one?
It's a string of characters.
That tells the computer how to interpret those
ones and zeros in memory.
The types that you get to use can
differ a bit between languages.
But in general, you’ll at least have:
Integer or INT.
That’s a whole number that can’t have
anything after the decimal point.
And those are extremely useful
for storing things like
the number of times you’ve looped
through some code,
or how many points
your player’s clocked up,
or how many pennies there are
in someone’s account.
Then you've got character or CHAR.
These are letters, numbers,
punctuation, and whitespaces,
like the space between words,
and instructions to start a new line.
And in most high-level languages,
you’ll probably be using a STRING instead,
which is just a string of characters.
Then you've got Boolean, or BOOL, named after
George Boole, an English mathematician.
That's very simple: it's true or false.
A boolean only contains either
a zero or a one. A yes or a no.
A no or a yes.
Nothing more.
Then there’s floating-point numbers, or
FLOATs.
Floats are complicated and messy and a whole
other video, but in short,
they let you store numbers with decimals,
although you might lose a very small bit of
precision as you do it.
There are others, other types,
in a lot of languages,
I know it’s more complicated than this:
but this is just the basics.
So. Most languages use
“explicit type declaration”.
So when you declare a
when you set up that bucket,
you have to also declare its type.
So, x is an integer, it can only hold integers,
and right now, that integer is 2.
But in some languages,
including some popular ones that people
tend to get started with, and that I like,
you don’t need to actually declare that.
It just gets figured out from your code.
That’s called “implicit declaration”.
So in JavaScript, you can just type
x = 1.5 and it’ll know, that’s a number.
Put the 1.5 in quotes,
and it’ll go, ah, it’s a string.
So, okay, it’s storing 1.5 and “1.5”
as different ones and zeros.
Why does that matter?
Well, in JavaScript, the plus sign means
two different things.
It’s the addition operator,
for adding two numbers together.
But it’s also the concatenation operator,
for combining two strings together.
So if x is “1.5”, you ask for x + x...
it returns 3.
But if either of those xs is "1.5", a string,
it'll return that.
And that's called “type casting”;
converting from one data type to another.
Some languages require the programmer
to explicitly request the conversion in code.
Other languages, like JavaScript there,
do it automatically.
JavaScript is referred to as having “weak
typing” as opposed to “strong typing”.
And it’s weak because, even if that 1.5
is a string,
and you ask for it multiplied by 2…
it’ll return 3.
Unlike the plus sign, that asterisk can only
mean ‘multiply’,
so it can only handle an integer
or a floating-point number.
Give it a string, though,
and it won’t throw an error like a
strongly-typed language would.
It’ll just convert it for you on the fly.
Really convenient.
Really easy to program with.
Really easy to accidentally screw things up
and create a bug that’ll take you hours
to track down.
Or worse, create a bug that you
don’t even notice until much, much later.
In a lot of languages, you can also cast
to and from boolean values.
Which is called "truthiness",
and experienced programmers who are
watching this may already be grimacing.
Truthiness is a great shorthand.
If you convert an empty string to a boolean,
it generally comes out as false.
Anything else, true.
So you can just test for an empty string with
if(x).
But that also means that in JavaScript,
you can ask for true + true and
it’ll tell you that the answer to that is 2,
because when you cast ‘true’ to a number
you get 1.
In PHP, a language notable for many
questionable design decisions,
even a string with just a single zero in it
will get converted to a boolean false,
there’s a special case just for that string.
Which can cause a lot of unexpected bugs.
Now, there is a workaround for that in
loosely-typed languages.
Normally, if you want to
compare two variables,
you use two equals signs, like this.
You can’t use a single one, because that’s
used for assigning variables.
I’ve been coding for about thirty years and I
still absent-mindedly screw that up sometimes.
Now, if you ask if 1.5 is equal to “1.5”
with two equals signs in JavaScript or PHP,
you’ll get “true”.
But if you add a third equals sign,
then you’re asking for strict equality.
If the data types don’t match,
any comparison will automatically fail.
So why is all this controversial?
Well, languages like Javascript and PHP can
get a bad reputation
because they use weak typing.
If you see yourself as a Real Programmer --
and I’m using that sarcastically,
but if you see yourself as the kind of programmer
where you are in control of everything, then…
yeah, you can see that weak typing
is like training wheels,
something that introduces sloppy
coding practices and bugs and shorthand.
And that’s not unfair.
But weak typing also makes programming
easier to learn and easier to do,
it can reduce frustration and
just make programmers’ lives easier.
It is a trade-off:
even if it is a controversial one.
This series of The Basics is sponsored by
Dashlane, the password manager.
It’s kinda obvious that passwords are more
secure the longer they are,
but it can be difficult to get an intuitive
sense of just how much more secure.
So let’s say you’ve signed up to Dashlane,
and now you’re able to use long, complicated,
symbol-filled passwords everywhere
because Dashlane remembers,
synchronises and autofills them for you.
How much more secure are those passwords?
Well, let’s do the maths.
The characters that most web sites tend to
accept for passwords are:
uppercase and lowercase letters, numbers,
and let’s say thirty punctuation marks.
That’s 92 characters.
There’s an argument that you should be allowed
to use any Unicode character in a password,
but it’s definitely an argument,
so let’s limit it to those 92 characters.
First, because we’re using random characters,
we can ignore ‘wordlists’
that make password cracking orders of magnitude
easier by guessing dictionary words first
including, like, using an exclamation mark
instead of a 1,
or deliberately swapping a couple of letters.
Those tricks won’t work here.
Now, let’s say that an attacker
is able to test
a billion possible passwords
every single second.
That’s not unreasonable if the encryption
is weak and their computer is fast.
If you have a six-character password,
it will take them at
about ten minutes to try
every single possible one of the
606 billion combinations.
But every letter you add
multiples that time by 92.
Seven characters works out to
15 and a half hours.
Eight characters, about two months.
Nine characters, 14 years.
Ten characters, more than a millennium.
Eleven characters is a hundred thousand years.
By the time you’ve got to fifteen characters,
it’s about a thousand times longer than
the universe has existed.
Long, complicated, random passwords aren’t
a cure-all.
But they’re certainly better than the alternative.
And to help you with them:
dashlane.com/tomscott for a 30-day free trial
of Dashlane Premium,
which includes unlimited password storage
and sync,
plus a load of other features.
And if you like it, you can use the code
“tomscott” for 10% off.